welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz today I'm
delighted to be joined by Stephen May
who is the co-founder of the vivid group
who are a group of recruitment companies
that operate in the healthcare optical
and tech markets they recruit both
Perman contract staff currently have 27
people across the group and have been
going for nearly a decade they've been
going for nine years
Stephen thanks for joining me thanks for
having me and been looking forward to
this and as you know we're always always
like to start on this podcast did you
propose we call Steve Oh Stephen
well only my wife and my mom call me
Stephen so cool so how did you enter the
word recruitment because you've been in
it a while so how do you get yeah
recruitment probably similar to most
people and I never really grew up
thinking that I want to be in
recruitment I had other dreams and
aspirations where not when I was younger
so and I started out I played football
full-time and fell out of that and and
naturally went into a sort of sporty
field so trained to be a PT was that by
the way like the sort of lot on the
scheming childhood dream become the foot
belong you fall out for them lose your
purpose what do I do now for this is it
for five years ten years away that must
be difficult yeah yeah absolutely and
you know I left school when I was
fifteen to go full-time to play for
Brighton yeah yeah just presumed like
most other teenagers at that age that
they're going to make it and gonna be
you're gonna be in it for ten years
financially comes to beer and
realistically it really is just the top
one percent in the world really never
actually carve a career out in
professional sports so yes falling out
of it I literally as you say didn't know
what I wanted to do how old is you at
that point and so when I stopped playing
full-time I must have been 18
no proper young men still still proper
young but obviously you know my my close
mates that gone to uni or you know gone
and done other other other things that
they would sort of carving out a career
path whereas I was in Brighton at the
time didn't really know what I wanted to
do and my mates dad actually gave me a
job he's got a telecoms company and yeah
initially started off basically packing
packing since the boxes and and selling
them out from from a warehouse and
actually it's probably one of the
biggest learning curves I had at that
age because yeah he actually sacked me
because I was because I was trying to
play semi-pro and work full-time and I
kind of just realized actually people in
the in the real world I call it that
actually have businesses they don't
really care if you still think you're
going to make it as a football if you're
if you need to leave at 3 o'clock to go
yes actually in the end he actually
sacked me which which I think they'd
give me a massive kick up the arse just
give you their perspective yeah bit of
perspective that you know you have to
sometimes you have to just be a bit
ruthless and yeah I still I still see
him now and I always thank him to doing
it basically made me decide to get out
of bright and I moved to London August
19 I'm trying to be a personal trainer
and realise that actually the actual
training people I didn't necessarily
enjoy it was more actually getting
people to sign up in my opinion the best
BTS are the best are the ones who are
the best salesmen I didn't actually
realize don't normally yeah yeah it's
just like yeah can get cool in that
corner I want to be a PD I'm passionate
about health and fitness but and then
it's like yeah oh I've got to talk to
strangers and talk to them about the
problems that having challenges they
have them yeah you know I mean yeah yeah
exactly that you've only got a look at
say John wicks for example like yeah he
might be a really good PT but actually
he's marketable and he only got
something that people buy like he
wouldn't just be working for Virgin
active in a gym now and being a success
that successful is here so here you have
there yeah
so it's essentially yeah I started
training a guy
got to sign up sip some sessions and at
this point I was like yeah I want to
start earning some more money obviously
as you know London is very expensive to
live and yeah basically I managed to get
a like an induction day with with Hayes
and I know this was actually through my
step-brother knew someone that work but
I I went there is the only person who
didn't have a degree yeah
didn't even shave so I just didn't know
the business you didn't go new track
season that like the final the final two
out of about fifty and basically they
said they'll come back to me with an
offer and then I went back to work that
afternoon I was training the guy and
said I'm think I'm gonna leave I'm gonna
take a job he's what we gonna do I was
at recruitment he was like well I work
in recruitment why don't you come into
my firm which was just down the road so
ya went an interview to them and
basically I think I was on like 12k a
year as a PT with with some bonus
obviously and selling and I think they
offered me like 25k and I was like
nineteen I was all-in and God's honest
truth at point it was just honestly I
didn't I didn't even really understand
what I couldn't understand how they
actually made money
they said it's a lot to do as sales
you're getting people to take jobs I was
like okay and you know basically so
basically join them instead of Hayes and
yeah I heard so I ventured in and then a
recruitment I love that so then so then
you weren't there for fighters at five
of us Oh years I saw and linked I think
I'll say for about four years four years
real stylist in in was right and a bit
of context so a lot of crews listen to
this likewise we've been thus owners but
what was that a big firm or was it a
sort of small grown business or at the
time they were I would say a small small
growing business I think it was about I
think I was like employee number ten
maybe powwow number 11 was the market so
they did they did farmer
they work with like GSK and a lot of big
firms but there was an another guy that
had come in and he'd actually started
doing some stuff on with high street
healthcare and I think at the time that
was where the need wasn't that was just
the market I was always put into I
didn't necessarily have a choice so I
worked very closely with him and yeah
quickly obviously came out probation
start doing deals that I'd realized in
actually this is you know if you work
hard there's a formula here where you
can actually make good money and at this
point on you know 2021 my mates are you
know living on student loans so when we
were going out you know I was going over
to Kingston a lot and they had like a
tenner to spend and I had like hundred
quid suspended so yeah you know I was
you know as the company grew my my role
within the company also grew and so I
became the manager of the department the
other guy moved on and I grew the team I
think I had like six or seven people by
noticing health care sorry yeah this was
in health care yeah so this was this was
sort of optical pharmacy dentists a
really high street health care and was
that a simple pan sorry to confirm the
plan yeah all right so which I which I
enjoy because you can kind of it's a
it's a slightly longer process obviously
than in contracts in and you know having
a lot of client contacts as well from it
from a young age I think really helped
me as a person I'm very comfortable
around all the people as a you know
growing up so I felt that even though I
was young in the market I could still go
into a meeting and hold my own
mmm nice I like that so obviously what
what I really want to begin to is is you
growing vivid group and you being a
recruitment business owner but just as
we were talking about this I guess in in
sort of hindsight looking back what what
do you think enabled Steve made to
become the manager of not just someone
that was an employee who just recruited
build.xml a month and then progressed
like how how did you catalyze
I'm in being that business and grab the
opportunity you had what do you pull it
down to do you think just for people
listening who wonder progress want to
meet the most limited recruitment career
how did you maximize that opportunity
and become a manager and leader in that
business you think I thought I would I
think it's it's if if you're if you're
the person that's first in the office
and last leaving at a young age I think
senior folks see that and go Jesus he's
hungry and I would always hope and this
is certainly how I feel now as a
business owner I would look at that
person to think yeah they've got the
grit between their teeth if they've got
something that they want to they want to
achieve and so for me
yeah for sure I I really do think that
the hardest workers within any business
will always do well or always do you
know always have least at least my
pajamas best at least on the transfer
yeah absolutely and you know I I
massively relate that probably my
sporting background that on yeah
extremely extremely competitive I hate
losing even if I'm playing you know at
home with my wife
I hate lose gonna ask that light I'm
sure it still translates now into you
being a business owner but I mean I'm
sure you it's like a proper typical like
background for a recruitment business to
look at isn't it yes the what seems to
be involved in alright competitive you
should be writing recruitment like it's
a proper classic thing to look out for
but I guess you've been in you planned
professional cleaning that top level
like how how did that actually translate
in the helping and recruitment and why
do you think that that's a real common
thing that people look for is is it just
been the being competitive or what what
other do things do you think at home
yeah I think a mix of all of them so I
think and you know when you play
competitive sport you've won you've got
a deal with pressure depending on the
level the level you player you know I
was playing in front of some big crowds
at the time so yeah dealing with
pressure I think also I was very lucky
in in when I was upright and my manager
threw out I've got a lot of respect for
him and still do now and I think
actually he instilled a lot of a lot of
qualities in me
I I stick through today in terms you
know type timekeeping for me was they
used to get fined if you were late so if
you allow two minutes of training you
get fined and I was only like 50 pounds
a week as a youth player so you know if
you're getting fined a tenner you know
you know if you if you if you have dirty
dirty boots add a kit that's fine
so all of these things really taught me
you know could priam presentable
yeah you know to turn up looking you
know looking your best no matter what
being on time dealing with pressure and
I think really resilience and mindset
trying to and and success isn't
necessarily a monetary value thing in my
opinion yeah you can you can be a
extremely successful postman so for me
it's not it's not about the money you
earned it's about how people perceive
you as a person and if I think and we'll
probably come on but you know leadership
for me is is people buying into you yes
it's buying into your vision it's not
just you know oh yeah this company's
really good they're gonna pay me loads
of money it's how do people buy into you
and how do people trust and believe you
that you're going to lead them in the
right direction so a lot of these values
that I picked up off of my coach deeply
milken's
brother of Ray Wilkins so he he he
taught me a lot growing up and I don't
think people be realizes that he did but
yes for sure and and he was taught he
was he was horrible at times think
really horrible but now I look back I
have a lot of respect for him as a great
man manager mm-hmm I know I think I
think I think that's I think when you're
in a small grown recruitment business I
think I think I think really for
whoever's listen don't really
underestimate sort of how much
opportunity there is and really build in
those relationships internally as you
said doing all those things that you
just said in within your recruitment
business will mean that Steve may get
the nod to become the first manager or
leader or you will enable you to present
or get opportunities that present
themselves to you and I think you're
completely right it's about how you
perceive this
people talk about you when you're not in
the room and ask if you really double
down on that put in the work be a good
person and that those opportunities will
come to you and if you want them as well
and I think that's really interesting
the way that you spoke about that so had
you always wanted to so I guess just to
sort of wrap that up then so I was gonna
say had you always wanted to have your
own recruitment business but like what
was your good bill of then like where
where did the confidence and where did
the sort of thought process come of
Steve who ya was a PT went into
recruitment for years and then now
obviously start your own recruitment
business like where did that come from
and where that the confidence come from
for that yeah I think yeah I've always
built and I've always been a always
being a good bill up and and you know
for me billing and doing well within the
business is is my sort of competitive
edge
I want out bill everyone in the business
even now I still bill now and I want to
out that everyone yeah understand my job
role is different and if I can if I can
help someone else out bill everyone else
then then for me that's that's just as
good but yeah from a young age you know
the competitiveness as always he's
always been there I've got two older
brothers that used to used to bully me
and beat me up so I've always I've
always had to fight to get anything
anyway so yeah I think yeah I just I
mindset I wanna I wanna I want to learn
as much as I can here and and then you
know I got to a point where I just felt
I felt and I felt like I'd probably
achieved everything I could that you
could within within within that business
and to be honest of you know I just
thought I'd go and join another firm I
never feel that I would start my own
business cuz you know they say I'm only
how are you 20 22 yeah 22 so I'd been
doing it for three years I'm 22 I was
like well I'll just go and work for a
bigger firm where yeah I can get I can
get a better base salary I've got more
chance to progress grow a bigger team
and and yeah I need a few places had
quite a few offers and then as I was one
of my clients he literally said to me
look
if you leave we will work with you we
don't like your fan we like you and if
you're not there we're not gonna work
with the fan so that's like that rang
that rang bells really with me and I was
not as planted the seed just planted the
seed yeah and obviously you know I've
had non-competes and stuff in my in my
contract so I had to look at well how
can I do this how can I set my own thing
up and essentially yeah I just thought
well I've got that interlude on 22 I'm
single
I've got no one depending on me a tea
urn what's the worst that can happen and
I know that jobs going to be there for
me in six months I love that why not
it's so nice so it's such an underrated
question to ask yourself that if stuff
like that I think because it really like
that but that's certainly what cuz
they're a hundred percent no damn sure
you still had voices in your head saying
Steve who you to do they should bend in
at three four years what you're like
who's like who's gonna take you
seriously blah blah blah um but I think
when if you really are having most
doubts lot ask yourself that question
what is the worst can happen and it's
that if it is that you you try and you
fail well I'm as you said I'm sure
there's there's gonna be a recruitment
business that you can go to and say look
I had the waste water bath start my
recruitment business I tried it and you
know what actually wasn't for me and
this is what family difficult and what
what that made me learn is that I'm
someone that is is meant to be employed
for someone and really of cymatics I
want to be a great leader in a company
and so I think it's such a great
question to ask yourself the canal for
that so if you so then obviously the the
water emotion and we've you thinking
about that what's worse can did you
start so did you start with someone else
yeah so I'm really well with with one of
the guys that I bought in and trained up
and and he was a really good bill up and
actually I mean we're kind of polar
opposites really with our outlet he's
very he's very cautious and I'm
completely not so but at the time I
guess we didn't know that that's kind of
that's come to come to light as we've as
we've grown and moving toward which and
don't get me wrong that that is a really
good quality to have and probably one of
the reasons why him and I have worked so
well together and moving forward so he
basically said to me look if you're
leaving I'm gonna leave I'm only here
because I'm really like
to you so I just said some alert this is
what I'm doing if you want to go 5050
you can do it if you don't
I've got no comment so I'll do it on my
own yeah yeah absolutely so to it to a
degree view people into me and took a
risk with me we just emotion and so what
was the game plan mate this because I
think that's what that the first year
taken the leap is what people are most
worried about I feel like people may
never get to that point but may always
think about so I guess what was the 22
year old Steve mabe game plan for this
then how are you gonna do you never had
your own business before and I remember
for 3-4 years good Billa what was the
game plan and so initially obviously we
what we didn't want to do was go in and
work in the market that we why because
obviously companies here but but also a
big thing for me is obviously being
outside by verse apply you don't want to
have just one market and and maybe we'll
touch on that and you know if we touch
on some of the corona stuff that's going
on because that's affected a lot of
companies that about 30 consultants in
one market for me I said some we don't
just want to have one market having a
non-compete for six month is actually a
good thing because it forces us to go
out and BD in new markets and get
revenue and build relationships in new
markets so initially so our business
from day one and still to this day has
been organically grown and self-funded
we've never taken a penny of investment
we've never had an overdraft we've never
had a loan so how much so it's a bone
but how much runway did you give
yourself like because I think that's a
good thing to some practical advice like
did you did you have like a six-month
runway if I didn't make any because I
think that helps with you making better
decisions because I think a lot of
people if they find themselves in a
position where they give yourself two
months or three months I mean I actively
ask people how much money should have
the bank or run when I should have when
I start my own business and the common
advice was three to six months so you're
not making decisions that I don't know
maybe force you to make the decision you
don't really want to make this because
you've got want to get money in the bank
and you're worried about not getting
money in the bank so I guess how much
where did you give yourself
to be honest we never really we never
really said right let's give it a go for
six months and see if it works it was
and maybe this is this is my mindset my
mindset was when we're at a point where
we can hire people when we're at a point
where we can move into an office or move
into a bigger office my my mindset was
never that this wasn't going to work
okay my mindset was always that this is
going to work so yeah if it means that
him and I don't earn a penny for a year
two years that's absolutely fine because
this will eventually work and yeah and
and don't get me wrong you know the
first six months to a year we pretty
much did did you know he was there he
was living at home so he was then he was
alright but I was you then he still in
London I was renting yeah so it's was he
working out of your room we both like in
our room and I lived in South London and
he lived in North London so there was a
lot of calls on the phone but actually I
look back now and that was by far the
toughest period of my life and and
actually now where we are now working
from home is obviously very very
different scenario but yeah and and for
me that that was a motivation our
motivation was less getting nothing the
bank so we can go and move into an
office yeah and and we literally moved
we moved to London wall and we literally
worked out
of a war of sorts called Mickey it was
at the bottom floor London buildings and
rats in there there was we we basically
share the DES but we made it work but
that I think I think being out of your
comfort zone or being in a position
where you have to fight that it's kind
of sink or swim I think is it shows the
integrity it shows the balls of someone
if they can get out of that situation
rather than up and and and him and I are
both very resilient and we we just
fought and worked really hard to make it
work and eventually got enough revenue
in to move into a bigger office and a
bigger office
so let's just some just just for a sec I
think as you said that first year was
probably one of the toughest periods for
you so just before we talk about how
things start to escalate evolve and
snowball I guess so as you're talking
about there in the situation where it's
sink or swim
which meant you just have to take action
there's no plan B it was gonna work
right so it worked from home how long
did it take to make your first deal then
remember and how did you reckon what
Marcus did you go for them how did you
think about that so we went into a
pharmacy market which neither us had
worked in but was very similarly aligned
to the optical market that we'd worked
okay in terms of the process in terms of
the hoops you have to jump through to
get on a PSL or there's a bit familiar
boo it was a different market which
helped but it was a different market
yeah so so that's that's the market we
thought well look the fees are lower
them than what our current market was
but actually there's some volume there
so we went off the volume initially just
we would rather have a little bit of
revenue coming in rather than just
trying to you know trying to land away
also yeah so we grew it that way by just
sort drip-feeding in for the first two
three months I think we did our first
deal probably actually within within
about a month we did our first deal and
yeah and it was just like it was to
probably still to this day it's my
favorite deal because it was like you
know we we had we had bills you have to
pay
we were like [ __ ] we actually really
meet this I yeah what we probably both
called the candidate about eight times
within when she was meant to join just a
moment ago in a hundred times throughout
the first three months to make sure she
came out of Novation so yeah and we and
then you know that went in well and then
we started dropping in a couple more and
and then and then we and then we can
really see the potential here of well
actually this is a good market let's
let's grow this as well and then you
know when we come out of our non-compete
in fact at this point I've got you know
we've got all of our clients contacting
us got that job we wanted to be squeaky
clean and yeah and you know respected
during the the other guy and even though
they closed down that market because we
just we just thought this note there's
no point nor worth it's not worth it
yeah and then just a quick one cuz I
think again this is what other people
are worried about they can't speak to
their clients for six months whatever
light was this just straight smashing
the phones right we've gone off this
market let's work out who you on the
front work for pick up the phone speak
to them just straight up BD make it
happen yeah yeah yeah absolutely so you
know in those days you weren't able to
send an email to someone on LinkedIn and
hope they come back to you know say oh
you know we were just a hundred two
hundred dollars a day just speaking to
as many people as we can and you know
when you know when you know there's an
end goal in in minds doing 200 calls for
hundred calls a day doesn't seem like a
lot now it is because now it's about
we're in a very different market in a
very big way of recruiting and know
people don't want to be had hunted when
they're at work you know they've been
rather a different approach so yeah that
was yeah BD and relentlessly as soon as
we got a live job signed off both of us
would go at it a million miles an hour
and we pretty much wouldn't stop until
we've got at least the shortlist of
three or four candidates in so that we
knew we were going to cover the role and
hopefully one of the four would go for
the job okay so last question on sort of
year one then I guess sort of just a
sort of
finalize that knowing what you know now
then what what advice do you think what
advice would you give yourself going
into year one that you wish you had what
would that be going into year one
probably know how to run a business
because to be honest of you him and I
just recruited we weren't we weren't
yeah we know how to run a business
that's something we've we've learned but
what I would have probably done is
actually learn a bit more about the
running in the business about PA ye the
idea was you most surprised about like
with business workers I think that's a
real quick that's a real common fingers
in it it's like what so I can't that's
why those businesses exist to help Steve
start his own recruitment business and
let Steve you just worry about billing
will do the rest so like what what was
you most surprised about well I'm a good
of this is what how what do I do like
and I was probably out to be honest with
you I was probably most surprised how
bad a lot of accounts answer it sounds
really weird but we had we had we've got
an absolutely amazing company that we
use now and they're you know our
finances and stuff but at the time you
know we were just two young lads in in
in a box room in in the city trying to
find an accountant and you know we had
three or four in our first couple years
that you know weren't doing things
properly word and leaving leaving you
know trial in touch with sounds late so
we would get penalized so yeah I think
from it from a business perspective
actually just understanding the atpa why
and corporation tax and actually
understanding and even personal tax and
things like that understanding it little
bit more so you can get ahead of it
because when you become a business only
you know everything's taken care of
usually when you're an employee when you
come a business owner and you're
thinking oh yeah I'm taking five hundred
pounds a thousand pounds out of the
business a month well this is amazing or
whatever and then 18 months on the line
you then get a taxable you like I I
didn't actually think this that you know
maybe because I didn't I did my thing I
love using uni or anything at that so I
didn't understand any of that and
obviously we don't get taught in schools
which I think I do think we should but
we don't
I don't really have anyone to lean on
that I could I could go look what should
I do here what should I do here so we
kind of we figured out the hard way but
yeah that's probably the biggest thing
is I would definitely align yourself
with a good accountancy firm yeah nice
okay
so leaving year one then so just
complete [ __ ] resilience and to just
mind settled we're gonna make it happen
what what did this sort of next two
years look like then so did you start
hiring people obviously assuming then
you'll see by that point you can back
took phone in your existing client your
old clients like what what did what did
your yours and your business partners
business that like sort of from year 1
to year free how the things change yes
so year 1 to year 3 I think the strategy
was really to grow sir I think we said
10 ok from we made our first hire I
think after after about 3 months of
being in in the office and then we and
then we obviously wanted to train this
guy I get get him billing and then yeah
within 18 months we'd said look what we
where we want to be we want to get
complete domination of the market in
terms of working with a lot of these
clients and to do that we need people
that can deliver so Luke and I got all
the business on and we had consultants
in delivering him and I was still
billing as well so yes from 2011 to 2013
14 week route yeah eight nine 10 and
naturally obviously need a bigger bigger
space bigger space and then I think the
the the bet the best thing we ever
actually did was when we got to a level
where we had some good consultants we we
kind of transitioned from you know a
one-man-band startup we needed to have
something else that actually attracted
people to us as well so we started
working on obviously some social media
stuff we started we moved into a really
nice office in the middle of the city
paid through the roof for it and but it
really it was a strange thing because
we'd gone from you know working in a bit
of a dungeon yeah in a basement to
pretty much top floor over at the Honda
City over at the ger King amazing office
and
actually three or four people kind of
left within a month or two really in
there because and actually when we then
sat down and spoke about it and we we
then bought in three or four more
polished more professional guys into the
business who really we really drove
forward the business that way so I think
the people that were left kind of
thought mmm the direction this is going
probably isn't for me I'm more I like I
liked working in the basements like
things say there's a really good as in
rhythms a really eye-opening change the
new people that were attracted to come
and work for us to the people that left
and that's really when we then we really
then started to think well actually we
can become the biggest the biggest
provider of staff in this market which
which which we did in sort of 2014 and
we still are today okay cool so we
always talk about I mean it always
always sort of say this but it's just so
ironic that sort of one of the biggest
challenges for people like you is hiring
for your own business so I guess during
that period obviously got got a nicer
office growing the business hiring more
people I guess like how and what was a
sell to people to join your business
because I think in London so many
recruitment businesses like what as you
said I think you've spoken about a lot
of people are to buy into you the vision
blah blah blah line what what was what
was the division to people and how did
you communicate that because I think
that that's what a lot of people
struggle when they're a business of ten
people eight people and find it really
hard to push past that and we've spoken
about this a lot when and you're a
business owner you're quite small
business sometimes you can sort of feel
like oh like you're obviously confident
in yourself and the business but like
why would they join me and there's all
these other businesses they could join
them the bigger and better blah blah
like how what was a strategy to and get
people in to your business like how did
you go about that was it just straight
peakins people that you currently
employed you Germany make certain
recruitment or would you go down the gym
speakings PT is like what was the how
did you how did you
get people to join your business yeah
I'm a mix of everything so yeah a lot of
the time you know people that work for
us we would we would obviously ask you
know anyone have you when we were
looking to hire do you know anyone that
that's interested get them to come in
and have a chat and and and and I think
I think what I think what really does
help is or was that I was still so young
you know yeah I still are still so young
so people were coming in my age a year
or two older than me that I'm
interviewing and they're not coming in
and meeting a fifty year old guy that's
a dinosaur and I said you know I was
always into things that they were into
you know I'm happy to go to the pub and
you know still happy to go out and get
this and yeah I always doing the same
things they were doing I just started my
own business a lot younger age I think I
think people liked the fact that we were
than we were a lot more it could be a
lot more relatable Connor a lot more
relatable and and and you know that does
help when you when you meet someone and
they can buy into or they can they can
and they can understand you and what
you're doing and thing you like and
things that you're going through so I
think that that definitely helps and
yeah you know we we obviously we didn't
really advertise as such but if we met
someone or someone that knew someone and
you know I've got and I've got a lot of
friends in London still and and you know
I think the beauty that I had as well as
some from Bright's and so I knew a lot
of people in Brighton and naturally a
lot of people moved from Brighton and
want to go in either in London and you
know so that was a good catch meant for
us being able to get people that I kind
of knew or knew someone that knew them
and was able to bring them in and
because I do think there's a small
business where everything's organically
grown and you know this it was our
livelihood I think being able to trust
your employees is a really big thing and
still I still believe that's that it's
there you need to be able to trust
people to to get on with what they need
to do and to come in and and and and
work as hard as I felt I was doing and
my business part was there
okay cool and I guess what I be
interested in because you mentioned it
loosely so did you have did you have
more of a model where you so you and
your business partner do more business
development and then early on the guys
with the
evarin so more of a 180 months yeah yes
so the majority of consultants would
just focus on 180 and and and actually I
think a lot of people seem to think that
being a 180 recruiter is a bad thing hmm
when I completely disagree because
business developing give or take doesn't
make you money and if you're in
recruitment to make money what do you
want to do you want to place be here so
you know we had a business model that my
business partner and I pretty much
account managed and and delivered into
the clients but the consultants all I
had to do was going get candidates so
and this is I'm saying a lot of people
think they think it looks good if
they're like oh yeah I've got a meeting
here or meeting here it's like that's
all good and well and it is good for
building relationships but you're in
recruiting because you want to make
money and it's not it's not an industry
where you need to have a degree or you
need to so we have a business model that
we had a lot of a lot of guys and girls
move in the business that they just
wanted to make money and to do that all
they all they need to do is just the
liver into the accounts that we brought
on and it was you know people were
coming in and they still like that now
in the optical market yeah it's still
like that with the genius we bring in
they they are purely for a year or to be
focused on delivering we've got two or
three guys that now account manage
because my business partner manages that
business and he he does the day-to-day
operations so he's not as hands-on in
the market so we've got two or three
seen you guys that manage the accounts
yeah it's the same business model so we
got two guys that manage accounts and
deliver and then we've got the other
guys that then just deliver on the jobs
because you don't you don't you don't
need everyone to be D because as you and
I know beating any any any process can
take a month two three four and you're
taking someone away who's a good biller
because the natural progression people
think is that well this guy's a good
biller so he should be a manager now
good builders don't make good managers
yeah
so if someone's a good biller let them
build hmm if they need to be
incentivized more bump up their
commission or incentivize them by doing
X amount you don't need to give them
management responsibilities in my
opinion and and that's the business
model we we have particularly you know
within the house
health care stuff because it because it
is a smaller industry so it's not you
know it's not an industry like
technology where there are a million
clients there's only a select amount
clients and if we're if we're the top
suppliers of all of them
there's no need you don't need to be
yeah you just need to deliver on them
sure so okay it's interesting because I
think I think a lot more recruitment
businesses are using that model I think
because I think also I think as well if
you're if you're a free 60 consultant
and business development is is just you
find that really difficult and then all
of a sudden there's a career path that
you can just focus on the delivery part
and that's actually what you're really
great at it's just a great option for
people I think again if obviously some
people do want to do 360 and then like
the opportunity to bring on their own
clients deliver blah blah blah but I'm
hearing so many more teams now that have
delivery functions and it's super
effective again I guess I guess I guess
part of it as well along with your point
is
oh like people think that they have to
do business whatever is or it's not a
progression I guess because I think
people associate that they won't earn as
much money do you know I mean because I
feel like typically I mean typically the
Commission structure goes up when you
bring on your own clients did you know I
mean so I guess it's a lot how did you
out of interest about how did you
incentivize your consultants on delivery
how was it was it just on a few per
placement you get X fee or was it that
was it
quite lucrative like how did you make
sure that these people were incentivized
yeah yes so our commissioning and in
obstacles is um capped so okay
essentially if someone's doing 2 3 4
deals a month and they want it they
still want more money then we'll
incentivize them ok so if you do over 4
bills this month or if you do either X
amount this quarter will give you X
bonus give you and it can be monetary it
can be will give you a holiday will give
you extra days or whatever whatever is
if they want to be a manager and they
want to manage an account that is
absolutely fine we can't give them that
but I wouldn't just say to someone you
can be a manager if they don't fully
understand actually 50% of your time now
and be taken up with some leaking sahaj
are speaking to line managers and
dealing with that's that 50% that you're
currently just spending sourcing
candidates is now gone so we do give
incentives for account managers so we
give incentives if someone places into
their account they get they get they get
a they get they get a bonus per
placement so we mix it but you know as I
said I think good good good builders
don't necessarily make good account
managers or good good team managers
because it's certain qualities and and
on the flip side you can have a really
good account manager than the client
absolutely loves doesn't mean they're
the best biller bird but they are vital
to the business as well so you've got to
find the right balance yeah okay cool so
I guess how how did you what so coming
into OC year three or four growing the
business got a nice no office etc like
what what was the strategy to grow then
because I guess a lot of people get
caught I mean the majority of the
recruit UK recruitment market is made up
of where your business was that for
three four years and that sort of sub 10
staff that's a percent of the UK
recruitment industry so I guess like
what again I know it's all what happened
organically but sort of in hindsight
what was the things that you think you
did well that enabled you to break
through that typical glass ceiling of
recruitment business owners that are at
12 staff and keep hiring two people then
their dues to people or can't get past a
1518 headcount light what was the plan
to sort of push this business forward
them and so for me my my long-term goal
was to always move back to Sussex so you
know I was coming up to being in London
for nearly nearly 10 years you know it's
2016 now maybe so we've been going for
four sort of four or five years and
we've grown the business to a really
good really good pace and and having two
senior guys that was me and and Luke and
actually we've grown the business to a
point that I I felt like I needed to do
something else I wanted to do something
else I wanted to go into a new market
and and try something else is what was
you doing at that point then what
you'll roll so so my role so day to day
today day to day I was more account
managing doing the training billet
billet billing still and ultimately
that's really been my my main alongside
running the business but my function
within within the business at the time
was more you know taking the guys out
there and you know I was more the guy
that that sort of led from the front and
the area that really helped help the
business together from operational
standpoint as I say completely fits in
so he's quite cautious and I'm I'm less
say so we really worked really well so
I've kind of got itchy feet and really
wanted to do something else and because
you won't believe the blood anymore I
tried four or five guys you know really
really good builders you know we had
guys doing 253 okay a year consistently
for it for a couple of years and and I
felt you know actually I was still doing
so undecayed and and I was like well but
someone else can do that there's enough
work there for somebody else to pick up
to pick up the stuff that I would do so
and we built up enough revenue and and
and and really it was you know good
really good friend of mine that went to
school with who worked for a firm and
Technology found down in Brighton and
him and I had always spoke on nights out
and and when we got together and I've
always said that we should we should do
something we should definitely do
something when you're ready let me know
and I was really coming to that point
where I was ready and he then messaged
me kind of out the blue and said yeah
I'm ready let's meet so that was that
was late 2016 start of 2017 so various
discussions with him about the markets
and and really preparing how I can
integrate myself and move and set up a
new office down in Brighton okay so this
is under the vivid group and this is
great so so basically Luke and I met
with and yeah and and really just I felt
this was a really good time to to branch
out diversify I thought the business
London was was really a good stage and
we've had enough revenue to fund a new
business for six months to a year as a
minimum without making any money yeah so
by that point so sorry so by that point
just for context you all see back
operating an optical which is obviously
historically what he did and what you
didn't obviously the pharmacy stuff as
well at that point as well yes
everything so the maintenance the
optical market yeah and that was doing
really well but we still doubled in in
the other markets as well and I really I
just I just fancied doing something
completely different I just really have
to try my hand at something different
and just and just give it a go and again
it sounds to my mindset was yes I mean
the what you know now the stakes are a
bit higher because essentially I'm
managing myself out of one business to
then go into another business but you
know what what was what was the worst
that could happen yeah we might lose we
might lose X amount of money hundred K
awesome in the week that we'd asked to
invest in it hung the upside was that
we'd have a new market that is 10 15 20
times bigger than the market we're
currently in here so you know that was
the risk that I took and it did coincide
with my wife's from from Louis and then
I used to come down we used to come back
on the weekends and go to Louis and I
absolutely loved loved the area and and
really loved our family so I was like
yeah I want to I want to move back out I
want to move out at London I'd say yeah
I'm nine nine ten years so and it will
just you know the timing really really
tiny were there Burnham yeah and then
okay and yeah so we launched the
overlords technology in 2007 seventeen
and and that's just that's just a
grenade okay and then just so let's dig
into that so just just to help me
understand in the context so was the
communication so obviously was the the
tech part part of the vivid group right
that was that was the plan right so I
guess yeah so was the communication to
the people you build relationships with
that you got them up to become really
good consultants blah blah blah was lot
was a communication to them like it
wasn't oh you're not gonna see me
anymore I'm bailing out and we starting
something new it's so this is like how
did you communicate that because I
you don't want that's common question no
no no absolutely and and I do think a
lot of people were disappointed that I
was I was leaving and moving and setting
up a new office but the communications
will look that the the company is
growing or growing at new markets the
opportunity for someone to step into my
shoes now is who's hungry has to go and
grab it with both hands and run with it
passing over the torches to someone who
wanted to you know who wanted to step up
and and and and that the communication
was you know I still got in London so we
got like you know English see me again
it was just more like I'm not gonna be
the guy that's leading by the front
anymore yeah yeah absolutely and
everyone you know I think everyone I
think the most people most people
probably knew that I was at a point
where I needed a new challenge I needed
to do sneer I needed to do something new
and yeah I think everyone was everyone
was really supportive which is good okay
so when so when you started with so
citizen you said yeah okay so - yeah and
he he had a really good friend as well
that wanted to come and work work for us
so yeah the turbine the turbine came in
which is which is really good okay and
so then I said then what was your
involvement this point then was you back
to learning the new market again on the
phones yeah what was the crack because
that was a much we did you just go
involved so they told you Oh see I'm
sure they said to you Steve this is our
plan these are the market of iñigo ever
this is our sort of strategy as to how
we're going to do it and then what you
just plugged in and said right okay I'm
gonna help you make it happen
yeah so I think the beauty of it was is
that I'd obviously set up and run a
business for six years
yes allow those guys yes and those guys
you know they bought that the knowledge
of different tech sectors yeah I bought
the knowledge of how to run a business
so I basically said to them let you
teach me about the market market and
you've worked before I can teach you how
I'd be need and how I get candidates and
alongside that I'll teach you how to run
business I'll teach you how to how we
can grow this business together
essentially so
you know again very fortunate they both
they both bought into two months of my
vision and what I saw and what I could
see and how this company could grow and
and massively I bought into those two
and absolutely love and both the bits
and you know it's it's it just worked it
just it just worked we're all for all of
the same age we're all just about to get
married or just go hang out so we were
all like we were all going Linings again
and we could empathize with each other
so yeah absolutely
we were all aligned with with what we
wanted to do and but yeah I mean my wife
did say she was like you know why why
are you going to learn something
completely new that you know nothing
about and I knew nothing about the tech
sectors at this point absolutely nothing
it's something that I've learned and
something I've really enjoyed learning
over the last three four years so yeah
we got an office in then in Brighton and
again it was kind of back to square one
though they need revenue let's pick up
the phone let's go back old school we
need to pick on the phone and again
those who had non-compete so we didn't
want to step on anyone's toes we went
off to completely new clients slightly
different sectors and again for me it's
a good thing because it teaches you to
get out of your comfort zone and to go
and learn a new market that you don't
know but you need to make work that day
I think hunger hunger in any business or
sport or anything is so important to
have that to have that hunger you look
at most of the best sportsmen or sports
women in the world a lot of them come
from nothing yeah driving force no Plan
B so what I mean there's no plan B you
know look at the Williams sisters like
they came from the worst place in the
whole of America to become two
integrates and it could because they
having that hunger for me is massively
important you need to strive to get
something mmm okay so as we talk about
the sort of latter end of we're coming
up to today then I guess it'd be
interesting just to get your thoughts on
how how different did that those first
year two years how different were those
first year two years compared to you
starting in your dungeon in your bedroom
do you not I mean because you've learned
a lot from a long way so I guess what
what did you do differently
I think well I was almost obviously a
lot more prepared yeah isn't this
perspective everything was everything
was set up
you know we've got absolutely amazing
accountants yeah
the infrastructure absolutely you know
hosted having hosted desktop so you can
work from wherever yeah everything was
set up you know so we could really just
concentrate and focus on bringing in
revenue from here they won and you know
we had a target I think of like 200 or
something in the first year and we
absolutely blew that out of the water
and and did really well in the first
year why do you think you blew that
there were a couple of reasons really
one and then who is the best VDI you
know he he just knows how to throw and
ask the right questions yeah and you
know his job briefing or his intro into
a client is phenomenal
well is this I in Mel or on the phone no
no this is on the phone he's just an
awesome awesome
yeah and then and then almost
coincidentally and I didn't know this at
the time but the other Ben that I
brought in is by far yeah okay yeah and
then somewhere within that I kind of fit
in together so the three of us together
it it just worked and a good team it was
just a really good team and you know we
all got on really well and and it just
it just worked
we're in Brighton and and then you know
we were able to hire revenue was coming
in and we were like right let's let's
let's move and again it was it was
basically the same process that I'd gone
through but it was a thousand times more
a thousand times quicker you know it all
happened so so much so much quicker and
that is you know hats off to dosti
because they really bought into the
direction that I thought we could go and
and now you know the three of us are all
of the same mindset that we we just want
to continue to grow and continue to push
the consultants that we have in that
business and and we've got some amazing
consultants in the company now and yeah
we're in a we're in a we're in a great
position now to to keep to keep growing
and keep progressing isawesome so how
many of you guys are there
that under that so in the in the
Brighton office there's eleven of us
cool so we've got an office manager
she's absolutely awesome
she she's actually made me realize that
I'm a control freak which is which is it
which is actually a good thing and she's
really has to like force me to just let
her deal with that with a lot of stuff
so yeah yes so we're at 11 now and that
you know and again you know organically
we've diversified the markets we're in
so we do various different markets
within within SEC and one of the guys is
growing a new a new market in sort of AI
drug discovery one of the girls is has
come in from a temp from a temp
recruiter into a permit roots and she's
absolutely hit the ground running she
she's growing a new market so we just we
just stopped spreading and spreading you
know spreading out which and I guess
we'll come on so which is why we've been
able to continue as as normal as
possible you know that's what's going on
that's why I was gonna segue into May I
guess Steve today then the business
owner yeah what what what's been going
so obviously everything that you've just
said there make sense right so and was
that was that intentional I know you
said from this all day what you reckon
like you didn't wanna you did you
consciously not want to have all your
eggs in one basket that was that was
always the plan yeah yeah the only
reason why I think that's interesting is
because you always hear the advice now
in recruitment of this of inch-wide mile
deep obviously you still in tech and
there's obviously I'm assuming it's
niches within tech right I guess it's
just interesting that you've consciously
made sure that yeah like you all all
your clients and relationships and all
the people that help you general help
you generate revenue and grow your
business isn't all in one place which
mean if they get affected you get
affected and go I mean so I guess how
has that helped you at that today then
and and how has that helped you in in
today's current circumstances yeah I
think well I think two fold really
firstly when I set up their business
initially in 2011 we were in the middle
of a recession so you know when when
this when this all kicked off I felt
very prepared for it because I'm used to
only work
on one job two jobs you know I'm used to
having clients pull jobs and clients go
look hiring freeze for six months or
whatever it might be so the beauty as
I've said because we because we're quite
diverse in the industries that we do you
know we don't have ten fifteen
consultants all working in the same
market all going off with the same
clients you know and when two of those
clients pull and you know you've got ten
people working on one job because we
have different markets and almost it was
conscious that we have different markets
and we didn't want to have everyone
working in the same market and we never
feel we never feel 1:1 market with six
seven eight consultants we will only
ever have two three four concerns as a
maxime in one particular market because
that enables us to either pass off jobs
to someone else so at the moment we've
got a couple of people that are working
in a market and works on
similarly aligned but they're adapting
to a new market and and also I think a
lot of people you know the people that I
have particularly in the tech business
at the moment you know they all have a
value they are all very very critical to
the business I think a lot of companies
make the mistake of they move into a
bigger office and they've got 15 desks
or let's just - people you don't need 15
people we don't you know your costs your
cost of the business and the office is
the same whether you have one person in
there or 15 so I think a lot of
businesses have probably struggled now
and that's of people on furlough etc
because they haven't really looked at
who's actually bringing in value to the
business yeah and do I need to hire
someone you don't need to hire someone
don't just hire on because it looks good
what other people looked really I think
now I think that's what I think so I
think that's one of the things that the
conversations that I've been having a
lot is that I really think this is gonna
put in check people like you of a
recruitment business owners that will
hang on a minute maybe I have got a bit
tangled in worrying about how many
people have in the office rather than
absolutely how many how many how how
many people in my office are actually
working at full capacity and how many
people are invested information yeah so
I think I think that is gonna put a lot
of that in check I think that's what's
gonna be interesting that those yeah the
the people that had that mindset of I
need 30 40 50 people
like you said got 50 new dare settings
on new 50 new concerns get them but in
100k Plus that means X revenue well
actually what look at the people you've
already got in your Falls first and
that's definitely gonna be interesting
that did you think yeah you think that's
gonna do you think that's going to lead
some more leaner smaller recruitment
businesses good yeah and I think I think
you know a lot of people will you know
before this is all happen they're like
oh yeah let's go set up an office in
America or or let's have another office
here and for me it's it's it's a bit
smoke and mirrors really it's like if
you have a genuine need to have another
office in a different country I
completely get it if you have a genuine
need and that that business there has
its own set of clients I completely get
it but if you can you know we're so
lucky now we can work from anywhere in
the world you don't need to be in that
country to do business in that country
so you know most of most of my clients
are in the US and that's that's that's
really the markets I work are obviously
on us time zones but I think a lot of
people we realized well I don't need to
just have that on our page and be
promoting my mixing that we've opened an
office in New York or wherever it might
be unless you have a genuine reason to
do it I think a lot of people now are
looking at going oh well I've got this
off is this of it an office in America
that actually doesn't make that much
money and everyone's probably gonna have
to strip back and return there is this
models in order to get through you know
and come out the other side and it will
be intact and still have people that
want to stay in this industry because I
think a lot of people will will probably
jump out of this industry as a result of
what's happened because it is volatile
and and you know there's no guarantee
that that you're going to have a job at
the end of it so yeah I do I do think
you're right I think I think people will
strip back and really really take care
on who they're bringing in and you know
am i bringing this person in as a bit of
an ego trip because we've got five more
desks or am i bringing these people in
because we have a client who have a
hundred jobs that we need bodies to be
filling these positions for yeah what
and what what have been what sort of
been the most difficult what's been the
most difficult part for you then over
the last couple of weeks would you say
for me for me personally it's been
I've missed the interaction you know day
to day I think Snow Queen is a nice and
my personality definitely lends itself
to being in the office giing everyone on
that that type of personality so to me
it's been that's that's probably been
the most difficult I've really actually
really enjoyed being at home and
spending more time with my wife and my
dog and that's been absolutely amazing
but I'm definitely ready to to get back
into the office and and and that's yeah
missing missing just the day-to-day
interaction you know being able to just
be with people like-minded definitely
agree on that and I guess like your
you'll clear someone that's resilient
and been through difficult periods I
guess what what have you been what have
you been focusing on day-to-day and
likewise I guess speaking to your team
about what they should be focusing on
day to day to make sure that you give
yourself the best possible chance of
achieving the outcomes you want right
now what are you focusing on so to be
honest my my focus and priority has
changed slightly from today to say
beginning or middle of March you know
over the last six eight weeks it's
changed slightly my priority really is
actually my all of my teams you know
London teaming and down here in terms of
just their mental state I think yeah you
know the this is going to have a massive
effect on a lot of people and you're
probably the same as same as me you know
I've had days where I've been really be
motivated and definitely that and you
know and and I'd like to think I mindset
I'm very positive but there have been
days where I've just been yeah I've just
felt defeated so you know there are
people that have you know a bit more
fragile state mentally that they're
going to you know stuff it and they're
going to be struggling here some light
my priority really is just reassuring
everyone within our business that you
know they have a job to come back to
when we're back in the office it's you
know we're not making any cuts we're not
you know we're not closing anything down
we know we have the cash flow to
continue and we're still doing well you
know so I think my
day to day really is just checking in
with everyone over the okay in yeah yeah
almost over communicating you know
what's that for each go and mental and
everyone's got different bits they're
sending in which is good fun but yet
really for me it's is just more about
the people because I think without the
people in your business you've got
nothing and if you come back to an
office that everyone is flattened and be
motivated you ain't gonna have another
months where it's gonna take it to pick
up so or even younger I think I feel
absolutely I think yeah I think I know
you've seen a lot online like try and
make the most out of being on furlough
or whatever I think I think one don't be
too hard on yourself but to I think
you'd be naive to think that sort of you
could sort of completely relax out for
six weeks free weeks however like it is
and it just pick up back at the phone
and get to it I think I think don't
underestimate the amount of people that
are wearing the storm right now and
trying to rise to the occasion doing
what they're doing and they will have an
edge over people that are just hiding
under a rock and wait for this blow over
I think it'd be really annoying you
could describe yeah I agree but yeah so
I mean our priorities have shifted
slightly in terms of where we want it to
be by the end of this year yeah it's
it's really disappointing so we had we
had our best ever quarter as a group
include one so I think we would have we
would have had our you know why we
definitely would have had the best of a
year but you know I'm definitely looking
at it as a positive that actually I
think and I think most businesses
probably worries that actually you know
working from home and and allowing
people to work from home as and when
they need to is definitely there as an
option I've been so proud of how my team
of and that's it and you know everyone
has really really stepped up to the
plate and is really accountable now and
you know to deliver on the jobs that
they're still working on so it is
there's definitely positives to come out
of it and I just yeah I just want to get
back in the office and get to the pub on
a Friday so look before we finish I
guess just one or two lot of things I
guess just sort of them just keen to get
your sort of final thoughts and
some final points on people listening
who either often chromatic neural
equipment business or sort of are
building their recruitment business
right now or our recruitment business
owner so I guess what would have been
the sort of key learnings viewed then
Steve is a recruitment business owner
over the last nine years that sort of as
always you'll go to advice or things you
speak about when people say Steve like
what your thoughts on this or what what
the things that come up for you when I
say what are the key things that you'd
want to communicate to people that want
to start on recruitment business or in
that journey right now good question I
would probably say it's it's having that
self belief and I think you need to you
need to believe that you're good at your
job
you need to leave that you can be
successful and I really do think self
reflecting and accountability is a
massive I think so many people now are
so quick to blame I don't like the
office I'll I don't know that I don't
like that you know I think you can only
you the only thing that you can control
is yourself how you apply yourself they
think I am how you react how you adapt
and and how you overcome that and I
think you know you and this is something
that I you know I don't blame anyone
else for anything anything that happens
is completely either my fault right or
wrong so I think for me that's been the
biggest thing is they're actually you
know being that's even the business
owner right point pointing the finger as
that as well that's when you know
success a little too pretty making bad
decisions and mentally that can affect
you yeah absolutely if you're not able
to grow your business as a business
owner and you're blaming your staff oh
no one's feeling well enough ya know
what are you doing so enable your star
to be able to build more what will help
are you offering what training what
advice what are you doing it's going to
enable them to be successful within your
business so yeah I think accountability
and self-reflection is massive and you
know I think everyone's had the time
over the last two three months myself
reflects really on what they do well
what they don't do well and how we can
adapt to that and
yeah I think for me massively
accountability as an individual and as a
business owner more importantly is yeah
absolutely what what am i doing to
enable my staff to one be happy to
achieve what they want to achieve in the
business and three want to come to work
I think that's a real important thing
you know I love going to work I would
you know it's my ta I can confidently
say I don't think one of my employees
dreads going to work I really I really
don't and that's that's a beautiful
thing to have as a culture where people
want to come in they want they want to
come in to work and hopefully this is
highlighted it for most people that
actually if you don't like your job go
and do something else it step up another
50 20 plus 15 20 percent if you can
because you you're realizing now how
much you appreciate it
it's definitely put that in check isn't
it light are you numb or you want to be
done because yeah I love that mate so
two final questions first one I normally
just ask people what you're excited
about what you're gonna shout about but
just for probably have to change that so
I guess what were you most excited about
to do post Kove it mate hopefully things
are a bit more meet the baby so yeah so
that's really my focus really is how'd
you feel about that for that I can't
wait I'm absolutely buzzing my wife's
been actually amazing she's just an
unbelievable person so she's she's she's
she's ready I'm ready and then yeah it's
gonna be an interesting you know
integrating back into the office and
then probably having to take time out
and for the baby but it's gonna be worth
it so that yeah for me really that's the
thing I'm looking forward to final
question just saw a poem words really so
if you could communicate to every single
recruiter out there they'd listen to you
their take on steve's advice it could be
a phrase a word a sentence what what
would you would you say to the people to
be listening to you mate and then take
one
what would you communicate to everyone
out there there's a saying that I read
when I was younger like 10 I guess
there's always always stuck with me some
succeed because they're destined to but
most succeed because they're determined
to me and that's really like a mantra
that I I love because it's it's familiar
it's just hard work I think the hardest
working people tend to tend to be
successful or tend to be happy and as I
said before success isn't the monetary
value think success is you being
fulfilled and being happy and whatever
it is that you're doing you know some of
the most successful people I know have
just been full-time months you know it's
not a monetary value thing so for me I
think happiness and success should go
hand-in-hand
I don't think there's any point being
successful if you're not happy yeah so I
think then I think you lived and
breathed that man I think it's easy it's
easy so I read this quote and it's a
great question better to say you've
lived and breathed that something that's
awesome mate Steve's been an absolute
pleasure thanks very much